on va démarrer avec un extrait que
j'adore dans confessions intimes il
s'agit des fans de chanteur dans un
reportage intitulé sobrement je préfère
cloclo à ma femme on est tombé sur
philippe un fan absolu de claude
françois qui est en couple avec marie
claude regarder ça c'est du très très
loin le seul problème c'est qu'à cause
de cloclo le couple bien sûr est en
crise
je sais que valérie bénaïm à il a même
problème avec la compagnie créole est
pas des possibles est que la france
n'était qu'est ce que je voudrais que tu
ton quand tu danses
[Musique]
mais il met devant dégager par lettre
que d'être aussi jeu de ces étudiants
avec lui ce combat sera très beau lui
remet un peu moins c'est tout plat c'est
bien tant mieux philippe parce que ça
puisqu'il est devenu philippe m'a pas du
tout pas du tout c'est pas des nouvelles
de tous d'accord qu un oui mais pas
selon m mais c'est vrai ça parce que les
gens se disent pas possible en fait
c'est la question qu'on me pose le
powell est ce que ce sont des vrais gens
est ce que ce sont des comédiens
maintenant on en fait tout est vrai tout
et c'est la vie voilà c'est la france
c'est la vie ce sont des vrais gens mais
leur couple était en crise c'est à
angers ou pas vont rappeler ben ça
s'arrange toujours d'accord en général
de l'amour ça paraît et puis quelquefois
chassez le naturel il revient au galop
bien sûr oui de film je suis une fois
tourner une émission sur un fan de
claude françois parce que donc je vais
dans ma région partager la passion des
gens des fans de claude françois et le
gars il a fait accoucher sa femme sur la
musique de claude françois dont elle
elle poussait il a dit s'il vous plaît
aux médecins est ce que je peux mettre
alexandrie alexandra et donc sa première
fille il l'a appelée alexandra il avait
une deuxième fille de l'appeler
alexandrie quoi élever
[Rires]
elle allait mélina merci les filles ont
fait un beau duo ouais tous les deux un
enfin surtout moi merci la note delphine
vu l année prochaine tu as toi tu fais
une saison incroyable non mais le truc
c'est incroyable mais non ça va nick &
cie ce matin sa femme n'était pas fan du
tout dans françois c'est lui c'était une
passion envahissante d'ailleurs quand on
va chez eux le salon est plein de ça et
donc elle a dû quand même poussé parce
qu'on sait que ça va être compliqué sur
du claude françois
si ça m moi j'ai un pote sa femme était
fan des gipsy kings le petit est arrivé
qu'une guitare chéri bien quelle manière
[Musique]
merci
cette superbe chanson pour mimie mathy
qu'on embrasse voilà allez les chéris ya
un autre délire ce que vous appelez de 2
ce qui
dusty aidez moi mon mari se prend pour
le king c'était un immense fan d'elvis
presley
alors regardez c'est incroyable ça ce
problème c'est que sa compagne julie
elle est moins dans le délire elle ne
peut plus l'entendre chanter sauf que
dostie il s'en fout lui c'est un kiff
heures en séries en référence à un livre
magnifique
est ce que ça fasse une pensée bas il
s'en bat les cacahuètes
carrie n'a ri lorsque j'entends rien de
ce nom cd c'est comme si je veux ma
musique ici touchante vraiment une
victoire oui c'est quand même cool non
au plus haut
enfin 20 20 ans maintenant non
spies ne peux pas y croire le gars est
personnelle qui les frères mais
regardez-moi ce petit qu'une automatique
je trouve que franchement ça lui va
hyper miyako équipe comme ça karim
oui ce sont des vrais gens bien les
pathologies comme ça des règles qui sont
tellement fan que voilà mais bien sûr ça
devient un truc complètement envahissant
et on ne vit que pour ça et c'est le
problème de tous ces femmes c'est qu'un
bout d'un moment ça prend le pas sur
tout le reste
et ça devient ingérable pour leurs coûts
pour leur famille et des gens qui se
prennent pour vous et qui ont des photos
de vous partout et tous à dire oui c'est
tout c'est l'inversé vous se tâtait où
j'en ai vu quelques uns des cousins
pakistani bien entendu que j'en passe
mais voilà rien à cirer sûr si on fait
un appel à témoin je suis sûr qu on en
trouverait bien écouté avec grand
plaisir tout cas j'espère qu'un appât
qui sont fans de guillaume genton
sérieux dérangerait oui bon on va pas se
mentir il ya beaucoup de gens qui
regardaient pour se moquer un peu joints
sur des témoins est ce que c'était dur
de les convaincre
quand vous les contacter alors ce n'est
pas moi qui les contacts directs y avait
des appels à témoins il y avait une
équipe de caster oui c'est jamais
évident parce que voilà en plus ont
tourné pendant cinq jours chez des gens
dans leur intimité la plus profonde
donc ce n'était pas toujours facile de
pouvoir trouver des témoins comme on dit
mais mais on avait une vraie volonté de
les aider et ça je pense que les gens le
savent pas fâché ça c'était pas là pour
rigoler nous on était vraiment là pour
les aider on a eu plein de moments on a
fini les tournages avec la petite flamme
qui coulait pas ce que valait y avait
quelque chose qui allie mieux on sentait
que ça allait changer donc vous rappelez
de philippe le dj dj alors qu'aurélie sa
femme elle est tour où le ça me regarde
quand philippe rentrer enfin à la maison
il file directement dans sa pièce qui
contient son matériel et ses pour
s'entraîner à la sono indifférent à la
détresse de ré je crois que j'embrasse
ça me fait plaisir de voir le cousin de
camille combal
mais oui mais en en faisant des stars
comme ça le temps d'une émission mais
encore des années après est ce qu'ils se
sont pas encore pris plus pour claude
françois pour elvis presley pour de bon
dj hero il était déjà bien dedans nous
on n'a pas eu tellement besoin les
pousser il n'y a pas eu à les pousser
oui mon taille non c'est clair qu'ils
sont fans comme ça mais je pense quand
même que les caméras ah oui accentue
énormément parce que ces gens là on en a
plus on a une habitude voire une caméra
dans leur salon est donc évidemment les
caméras sont là donc ils surjouent
énormément je pense pas que le mec seul
elle y apparaît ainsi michel est ce qu
ont frappé de michel y lire je suis
radin et fier de l'être
c'est un truc de ouf le gars il est prêt
à tout pour faire des économies
scientiste et orge adoré ces dos a pour
habitude de faisait bon nombre des
aliments qui constitue son garde-manger
son but vérifier qu'ils contiennent bien
le point indiqué sur la boîte qui
manquent sur le poids total c'est de
l'art n'a pour moi c'est de l'arnaqué
oui bonjour madame je vous téléphone
parce que j'ai acheter du riz long grain
et par curiosité je les ai pris et j'ai
pesé les les quatre sachets oui d'accord
merci en fous je commence à avoir un
hôte aussi c'est ma femme se comporte
comme une diva on en a fait la rencontre
de sylvie qui faisait vivre un enfer à
anthony son chéri dès le petit déjeuner
ça partait mal regarde la méta deux
secondes mais non mais je fais le
serment de ses bons et nous serons dans
will et dans le sud ouest est donc très
chaud vous que sucré n'a pas fonctionné
mais je propose que cette fois c'est
mort attend tu as déjà vu que tu
commences à faire des choses qui les
fait bien je suis désolé module est
maintenu et une foire à la voix de l'est
y avait là un frigo et la non suivant
c'est tout fait jusqu'au bout quoi
et ils ont été briefés là puisque froid
alors franchement en toute honnêteté on
l'est on les bris fait pas du tout
jamais la durée le mans elle était au
dos comme ça c'est incroyable et des
gens comme ça voilà qui est
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est parce
que justement il était aux abois
rappelle une tête juste au qatar je
plaisante faisait peur que sa double de
la pension alimentaire bien c'est beau
c'est phoenix on voit maintenant quoi
c'est plus de pension alimentaire mappy
de personnes bah non puisque non non non
moi ce que j'ai il y en a deux qui sont
majeurs ils sont grands d'accord le
troisième média et de chez moi
cinq ans du petit dernier je suis mariée
que sa mère encore d'accord damien
écouter on fera une spéciale ce sera un
gros prime time bien sûr avec les
avengers à l'échelle de minutes dans une
émission qui avait pour thème arrête de
te prendre pour john hay al idée on
était tombé sur une merveille
c'est un fan du rockeur qui chante avec
sa compagne j'ai un problème at il de
son idole je tiens à dire que je connais
ce jeune homme et je l'adorent il était
venu un jour à la radio je l'avais amené
sur virgin radio le matin et il chante
johnny aussi en crachant du feu et il a
failli se brûler ainsi que sa femme non
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai donc on
va là on a dû intervenir exclamé je
l'adorent c'est un amour de bec mais
vraiment il essaie d amour regarde
[Musique]
pourquoi chez moi
je suis
je
le lait
non
non là tu veux la chier c'est pas du
tout d'antenne paul tu veux la chier tu
fais chier doucement tu fais ça c'est
une scène on passe pour des ploucs tu me
lâches y est alors on l'appelle madame
on recommence ça t'apprendra
il est beaucoup plus sympa dans la vie
mon gentil elle le suit par la lame
suture et il est l'heure de voiture
était tombée en pas dû me rappelle était
venu à paris express
ça a été tout un truc et sa femme était
un amoureux de l'eau est en tout cas je
fais les gros bisous j'en fais des
bisous y voit là il y avait souvent des
fans de johnny mais le meilleur c'était
jean marie il copié le look de johnny il
avait tout tout tout de johnny sauf mais
pas là sauf la voix a marre il est
imperturbable il copie la star à la
perfection
lunettes noires gestuelle mimiques aucun
détail ne lui échappe
sauf peut être la voie
ouais
vous
ouah johnny sa franche
chance tu te sens bien wahou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est alors qu'est ce qu'il a une bonne
normal non après conduit la normale
c'est que quand on est persuadé que
johnny sur lego va en tout cas raymond
je te le dis mon amour c'est plus long
gala du met votre au stade sur la scène
s'est passée est pas bon karine en tout
cas est ce que vous avez réussi à aider
des gens comme avec cette émission
j'espère enfin je crois que oui j'ai
encore des nouvelles de certains qui
vont beaucoup mieux
donc c'est encore une bonne nouvelle
vous manque cette émission je les fais
pendant dix ans et j'en garde un
souvenir incroyable merveilleux c'est
que l'humain c'était vraiment génial
voilà maintenant c'était bien de passer
aussi à autre chose je vous dire moi
c'est une de mes émissions préférées
sympathiques formidables dedans et
franchement on s'est régalé et merci à
julien courbet 1 qui a vu
l'idée de cette émission lui